strategically applied force
to create the conditions for such a
political settlement on the original
portion of this
and then
subsequently commissioner syslak is
going to provide some donation
information and acknowledgement
and then i after that i will come back
to the podium and address the overall
investigation where we stand and where
we are going now reference the
investigation piece
i don't want to repeat of what i
experienced yesterday
it's an ongoing investigation so i'll be
limited in the details that i provide
you
but hopefully we can get through this
with some modicum of decorum
so please
don't rush me all at once when we get to
the question phase i will identify you
if you just raise your hand
sound fair
all right we'll get through this
okay so as matter is formality our
department has worked through the night
to identify all the victims of sunday
evening's mass shooting on route at the
route 91 harvest festival
we have identified all but three victims
we still have an active scene at the
grounds near mandalay bay so we ask
anyone to stay away from that area until
further notice
the fbi is working diligently to clear
that scene
so the question is the fbi versus us
we have
partnered with the fbi as i said from
the very beginning of this in the
investigative phase the fbi has brought
uh
a large amount of resources out of
washington dc to assist us with that
um so we the reason why the harvest
festival is still in continuation
of investigation is not only solely
related to the removal of the victims
but it's also documentation of the scene
so we're using
the best
practice technology to ensure that we
have complete documentation that's why
it's taking a longer period of time
associated with this so we we asked for
everybody's patience
as far as las vegas boulevard north and
south we anticipate to be open and
shortly in the next few hours
to benefit with commerce and what we do
as a community
all right the key component here is
resources and victim identification so
bear with me
i'm going to try to get through this the
best i can but the important piece is if
you missed a number
we are putting up on
lvmpd.com in the next hour
the listing of all numbers i shall
provide you today
and for people out in the public uh to
contact us if they are lacking this or
they don't see this broadcast
okay we're asking for anyone who might
have information about the shooting in a
criminal capacity or is a victim of the
shooting
to contact us via 311.
if you are out of state if you have left
since
the shooting
and you have discovered you are you you
feel that you have become a victim or
you realize you have an injury
associated to it
we're still asking you to contact us but
the out-of-state number will be
702-828-3111
additionally if you are local
and you have the ability to respond to a
local substation a working police
substation
locals are familiar with you have the
ability to file a report at that
location
now the family reunification
all that is occurring
at the family resource center at the
convention center located at 3150
paradise road
you can go there to file a missing
person report you can go there to have
contact with the coroner's office you
can go there to get answers to your
questions as far as family reunification
the phone number if you have left the
area
is
six 1-866-535-5655 four
now we went through a little short
process here recently where that number
was down we provided a separate number
but we will go back to that original
number because we have the technical
aspects of that fix
so i want to be very clear on the
difference
if you are reporting a crime or you feel
you are a victim of a crime 3-1-1 is
your outlet
or
a local police substation
if you are looking for victim
information
or family reunification the family
resource center on paradise road is your
point of contact
now personal property we were getting
several questions
throughout yesterday and continuing
today on people attempting to recover
their personal property from the route
91 scene
we are working out the details of that
we're in the planning phase of that and
we will have an answer for that in the
next couple hours
so lvmpd.com will provide an answer to
that
probably before we have another press
conference
so but we are working diligently to get
individuals who left
personal property at the scene back to
them as soon as possible
i anticipate it will not take place at
the route 91 location
but i do not want to give you
furtherance of clarification at this
point so you will be provided that
the other issue is donations
as you can imagine in any critical
incident the outpouring
of support
from private citizens corporations and
everybody else associated with concern
for the victims is overwhelming and we
appreciate that but it becomes a
point
where we can't manage it
now the red cross is unable to manage it
we are unable to manage it at the
substations
so
if it's hard goods such as water or
canned goods or stuff that is not
will not become perishable
three square
and catholic charities is accepting
those donations
so we're asking you to provide that
information to your listening public and
to accept donations at that point
so the areas of
let me give you the addresses for those
so catholic charities is obviously a
1501 las vegas boulevard north
and three squares located at 4190 north
pecos road
at this point i will uh
acquiesce to commissioner syslak
and he will give you an update on
the donation phase of this
as far as victim
satisfaction and then
i will return and we will conduct
a q a associated with the investigation
commissioner
thank you sheriff and we appreciate you
all being here today to give you a bit
of an update on where we stand uh the
fun that the sheriff and i set up
yesterday has now surpassed 53 000
individual donations
it's in excess of 3.7 million dollars as
we speak
i want to bring especially we need a lot
more resources we're going to need a lot
more money we've got individuals that
are going to need future surgeries and
and health and so forth moving forward i
want to acknowledge a few special
individuals not included in that total
of 3.7 million dollars last night a
private citizen called both the sheriff
and i and contributed five hundred
thousand dollars to the fund
that is not included in that total this
morning uh wayne and kathleen newton
called me and they have donated one
hundred thousand dollars that is not
included in the total
uh for those who want to contribute and
don't want to do it on gofundme you can
make a check to las vegas victims fund
and mail it either to the county office
to my office or the sheriff's office but
i just got off the phone with jim murren
from mgm international and the sheriff
and i both spoke to jim and
obviously they have stepped up in an
enormous manner with this community and
everything that they continue to do
and on behalf of mgm and their over 50
000 employees
they have contributed three million
dollars
to this fund so uh we appreciate
everyone's support the donations from
five dollars to now three million
dollars and there's a lot of need and we
are going to do everything we possibly
can to raise money for each of these
individuals so we appreciate you
continuing to encourage folks your
viewers and readers to support the
campaign it's las vegas victims
either on
gofundme or you can make a check for the
las vegas victims fund thank you all
very much
thank you
distribution
uh we're working through the idea of
possible distribution it comes with
we've already got some
inquiries i think it's going to be a few
days before we can coordinate how we're
going to distribute money
right now we're not looking at the minor
property losses that some people have
called on regarding
you know backpacks and shoes and phones
we're looking at more major expenses as
it relates to you know
surgeries medical expenses funeral
expenses transportation so forth
but we should have more details with you
we're working through the county office
and the sheriff's office to develop
something in the immediate future in
terms of where people can go who they
can call to start distributing the money
that people are most desperate so thank
you all very much
okay just a quick synopsis or current
status of the investigation i won't
reiterate what we discussed yesterday in
previous
press conferences
but we have
completed the investigation at the reno
property
and i'm sure the question will be
presented what what was recovered there
so it was numerous electronic items
additionally five handguns and two
shotguns
and a plethora of ammunition
so
we have served certain warrants at three
separate locations
that would be the room at the mandalay
bay
the mesquite location and the reno
location additionally we serve the
search warrant
on the suspect's vehicle located at the
mandalay bay um so i'm happy to answer
any questions
yes sir can you be specific about the
modifications to the weapons you made
them automatically are there different
versions what that could be what were we
talking about here um the question was
is there what are the modifications
associated with the weaponry
um atf is uh participating in that
evaluation i can't give you an answer on
whether any of them are automatic or not
but we are aware of a device called a
bump stock
and uh and that enables an individual to
speed up the discharge of ammunition
i don't want to give you any more
details on that but in partner with the
fbi the atf
they are
sending those weapons back east to the
fbi crime lab for further evaluation
you found that there
yes
yes absolutely that's the girlfriend yes
maryland authorities information about
she
sir
his motive about his movement so can you
tell us what that information is no we
don't have that information yet but i
will assure you that the investigation
with her is ongoing
and we anticipate some information here
from her shortly
no ma'am i do not
know here you go
just let me back up a little bit there's
a lot of information i do know okay but
it's an ongoing investigation and when i
say i do not know i may know
but
but
as you can imagine in a criminal
investigation we want to ensure
the continued safety of our community
and then all those questions are
answered
and we i assure you this
investigation is not
ended
uh with the demise of mr paddock
sure
yes
uh could you give us an update if there
isn't a faith on the victims and the
injuries and also is there anything new
that you'd like to involve and wondering
about
are you making any progress whether
you're going to specifics or not are you
making any progress on determining
uh no i'll answer your last question
first no
we are making progress but i don't have
complete answers yet um so i anticipate
a substantial amount of information to
come in in the next 48 hours
hold on let me finish the rest of it as
far as the injuries
you know it goes across the board
coroner commented on that yesterday we
have trampled injuries we have people
trying to escape
injuries of their own
device
we have gunshot wounds so if you're
looking at total type of injuries
associated with all their injuries and
the people that died
it goes across the board i can't give
you a percentage associated with gunshot
versus
other types of injuries are the numbers
though the general members 59 and 5.
have those changed
we believe the injury number has
decreased slightly
and when i say slightly maybe 20
because we had a double count error
occurring at one of the hospitals
but we're looking close and still in
close proximity of the number i provided
you sir
um
i can't tell you her current whereabouts
right now all i know is the philippines
and
we uh
we are in conversation
currently she's a person of interest
the girlfriend
yes yes ma'am the daily mail has
released photos that say it showed the
hotel room after the swat team entered
and it showed guns and ammunitions
inside many outlets are redisseminating
can you verify which is the legitimacy
of these photos
and should any other outlets disseminate
them
i can't verify whether they're
legitimate or not what i can tell you is
i'm very troubled by it
we have an internal investigation
occurring as we speak on how
those photographs were obtained by the
public forum
can you talk to what was found
inside that hotel room that the gunmen
knew specifically cbs news is reporting
that there was a camera
inside that room
was the gunman recording was the gunman
transmitting that video anywhere else
i'm not aware of any transmission but
there was cameras there was cameras
located in outside of the room and
inside the room along with the firearms
and he had set up how many cameras i i
don't know what the specific numbers you
know
um well i i anticipate he was looking
for anybody coming to take him into
custody so you have a recording of him
carrying out these cards no
that's not essentially what i'm saying
that is being evaluated the fbi took all
digital and electronic evidence into
custody and we are evaluating sure
yes sir
do we know if this man was targeting
this particular event or did he have in
mind perhaps another
event
in the las vegas area as a possible
target can you develop any of it no we
haven't developed that um
yet
i will provide you that information at a
later date to follow on that there's a
report
we're unable to confirm that
we're unable to confirm
out
we received a call at 10 08 p.m
um the best of our estimates and video
review uh he continued to fire
at a progressive successive rate for
approximately nine minutes
as you can see by any video you see in
the public space it was hard to
determine where they were coming from
once it was evaluated it was coming from
the mandalay bay as you can imagine how
hard it would be to pinpoint the room
from the outside
officers subsequently formed up teamed
up
and
moved over to the mandalay bay to in
order to locate and engage
but that was in conjunction with the
mandalay bay security now this is an
opportunity for me to tell you something
the mandalay bay security was fantastic
i don't want anybody assuming that they
are unsafe by
you know staying at one of our hotels we
would not have
engaged this individual in the time
lapse that we did
without their assistance we received
information via their their dispatch
center and or their operations center
their call center uh from individuals
staying within the mandalay bay that
helped us locate where this individual
was sequestered
hold on i want to finish her question
all right
and so subsequently that takes time as
you can imagine
moving from the location of the event
deciding whether you're going to help
victims
evacuate or you're going to decide
whether you're going to take charge and
put an element together and go engage
this individual
so we have we have a lot of bifurcation
of responsibilities associated
especially in a dynamic event
i i want to say kudos to those officers
that got together and said this is what
we trained for active shooter we're
putting an element together let's go
engage this individual and locate them
okay and that's what we did
and when the security officer was
engaged by the suspect we backed off for
immediate apprehension and swat team
formed and made entry
i don't have that time for you sure how
concerned are you about your office
facing weapons
absolutely concerned the world has
changed and um and you know
who would have ever imagined this
situation i couldn't imagine it and for
this individual to take it upon himself
to create this chaos and harm is
unspeakable
and
you know we have to try to spit ball or
what if these
situations at all points when we train
and ensure that we have proper response
and i think we did a fantastic job
mandalay bay security identified the
room before the swat arrived
no
uh well yeah before swat arrived but not
before my officers arrived um that
they were married or hand-to-hand with
my officers uh when we made entry over
to the hotel and it was a matter if you
recall yesterday i said between floor 29
and 32
and during that process of evaluating
the floors we received additional
information
where he was located and they
immediately responded
that's for us to evaluate in the
investigation
no they were throughout the venue they
even had some
victims
that met their demise outside of the
venue and then we had individuals who
had been shot
and they continued to run away and then
they passed away
several blocks from the venue
we also had
very heroic acts of people attending
the event we have numerous videos
depicting people attending normal
citizens providing medical aid and
providing transportation for victims to
get to the hospital sure yes
where my colleague sir the camera to set
up the room
it sounds at least i'm sorry if i'm
interpreting this wrongly it sounds like
he had sent those cameras up to give
himself a warning from the approach of
police officers you
indeed was the know
and i know you don't want to get in the
mind of a madman as you would
how would you judge this man's
preparation and determination to do this
based on that
i don't even need that
bit of information to make a judgment
this individual is premeditated
obviously premeditated the fact that he
had the type of weaponry and amount of
weaponry in that room it was pre-planned
extensively and i'm pretty sure he
evaluated everything that he did in his
actions which is troublesome
um i i was hoping
you know i pray that in these situations
that a citizen because we can't be at
all places at all times that assists and
see something says something and we act
on that quite often what we experience
in our line of work a citizen thinks
it's trivial and they say no i don't
want to bother the police we ask you to
bother the police
because those individuals especially
housekeeping type individuals or any cab
drivers anybody in the public space that
can assist us we asked them to come
questions
at any knowledge okay let me ask back
here ricardo
security cards fire any shots
anything during the encounter
um during while he was discharging his
weapons we are not aware of that
no security guard or police other than
the encounter at the room
can you expand on one when right i know
you practice from the scenarios like
not exactly this scenario can you expand
on what went right
you know what i'm glad you asked that
ricardo because
obviously people have the assumption
things went wrong
in this type of carnage but what went
right is we saved
hundreds of lives
in an event and this guy have an ability
with those weaponry
the carnage that could occur outside of
what did occur
uh a lot more was prevented because of
our police action in short time and
private security action in short time
to save some lives
with all of this in the room that's the
cameras now the guns everything else
yesterday you had said that there had
been
hotel staff inside that group during
this day is that still believed did he
turn away housekeeping could houston can
go in there during this time um the only
thing i know at this point is room
service was provided sheriff can i ask
you a movie that i'm
[Music]
yes i do
why is fbi
i'm so glad you asked that
no i am i'm not being uh sarcastic
um
we're doing good
i'm actually very proud of our people i
mean
this guy here is the local sac
aaron rouse
in charge of the fbi
you know what's important greg castle
talked about this yesterday the chief of
the clark county fire department
i'm telling you right now this
jurisdiction has the best partnerships i
believe in the united states as far as
public safety
we would not be able to accomplish what
we did as you described in the last 48
hours without that partnership
the fbi stepping to the plate to help us
with the evidence documentation and
prosecution
the fire department
here's he didn't do a good job
describing it yesterday greg
the fire department in our jurisdiction
marries with a police officer during a
critical incident i beg you to find
such a robust
type operation in the rest of the united
states
quite often what you observe in the
public space is the fire department will
wait until it's secured by public safety
before aid is render our primary mission
is aid
and the safety of the public
they took it upon themselves
to train with us to marry with us and to
go into the fray to assist the victims
if you look at the video you quite often
see individuals with helmets on and
vessel on those are firefighters
standing next to us so i think it's very
important for you to ask that question
it's very important for me to convey the
answer
but the next 40 hours we'll be able to
tell
we've gone into
incident management mode
so in other words people have to get
sleep and nourished and and because we
don't want to make any mistakes in the
investigation
yes
um we do have some information i'm not
at liberty to say at this point
and there's there's the guy i was just
talking about make sure you get him on
camera
all right
yes ma'am have you been in communication
with the philippine government yes
they've been cooperating with the
whereabouts of nutanix yes we have
sure
okay
before we get too long and too um
contracted in this press
interview i'll ask your answer your
questions ken i'll ask you a couple
additional more and then i want
acknowledgement of the people standing
behind me as you can see it's our
congressional delegation and our other
public safety officials and
it's very hard for them to conduct
federal government and local government
while they're standing behind me but i
think it's important for you to realize
their community support and they want to
be there
amongst everything else they do to
ensure that people understand we're
bringing all resources
associated with this to bear in order
for we meet success
go ahead ken the first the first one is
to button up the champion's question
there's a report
that he had booked a camera on a service
cart in the hallway and the security
i'll tell you what i wish i had some of
you on my investigative teams because
it's amazing it's amazing some of the
information you come up with but i'll
confirm it yes one of them was on a
service cart
another question
is
the one that i wanted to give to you
talked about motive you talked about
premeditation you want to learn what why
he did what he did videos
can you tell us the number of interviews
you're going to have to do to do that
you talked about you're reviewing
cameras videos computers
who do you last talked to
um
i'll take i'll give you a global answer
on that yes yes to everything you said
yes we are evaluating all that
i can't give you because the number's
changing it's fluid ken on the number of
videos we're evaluating just on body
camera videos we had over 67 videos we
evaluated
okay um
so you would say well you had a lot more
officers at the event than that sure you
only had 67 no not all officers are
assigned cameras because they work in
investigative function or plain clothes
but when they take on the role of
special events over time
they don't we don't require them to wear
body cameras
so we are evaluating those cameras as we
speak we have 90 of that done but then
we have all the um
the common public space cameras that
we're evaluating
um and i can't remember the rest of your
question i'm sorry we're also talking
about the computers
and his cameras right
so a lot of this you're probably saying
well jesus shares it's 2017. how come
it's taken so long for you to evaluate
that
because it's evidentiary there's chain
of custody issues associated with that
we have to ensure we're dot in the eyes
and crossing the t
because you know there's criminal
defense attorneys out there right and
there's this thing called the
constitution we have to ensure that
we're abiding by that
and we ensure that
i don't know if we have possible future
prosecution
you know you heard me say that we're
comfortable that we have the suspect
into custody but something more may come
of that investigation and i want to
understand the motivation that you
describe
okay to prevent any future incidents
and you know did this person get
radicalized unbeknownst to us
and we want to identify that source
and then i'll answer the president
question does the congressional support
include uh
uh that's not for this form that's a
long contracted discussion that's not
for this forum
if you can tell us what the president's
plan while he visits las vegas how long
do you want to be here for
you're correct in who he's visiting and
i it is a matter of uh
secrecy and upset operational security
that i can't give you his travel plans
um and that will be
obviously provided in close proximity of
his arrival
ma'am i can't answer that question
because of operational security but as
you very well know you have the
resources to determine that upon his
arrival
and i can't speak to what his agenda is
what i can tell you on part of your
question was
what is normal protocol when the sheriff
i'm not sure if the president
the president or the vice president of
or anybody of dignitary space of that
equality
we ensure their safety by the
joining forces basically it takes
a great deal of resources ensure the
safety of the president and we will
provide that because of our public
cooperation
through nhp north las vegas
henderson boulder city as you can
imagine all the people will come to bear
now important piece on that is the
president's visiting
route 91 investigation
and if you don't if you recall i'm a
police department
so we have over 3.3
million calls a year that we deal with
so we have to continue with our
investigations
our response
and normal police business in order to
be successful so
i ask your cooperation and don't get
frustrated if i don't have a press
conference every five minutes because i
have a job to do and my folks have a job
to do so i want to thank everybody for
attending today and hopefully hopefully
as a result of your attendance and your
broadcast this investigation will
be not as long as i wanted to be
you've been very transparent as far as
messages yes can you say that again
can you say it again please
say it again rachel
reporter you have been very transparent
in the past about metro's de-escalation
tactics in pulse which was a mass
shooting there was talk at the time of a
very delayed police response trying to
decide when to make entry can you talk
about the decision to make entry into
paddock's hotel room
well i will not disparage another police
department's response
but i will tell you we quite often learn
from what other people do
and everything we do on a critical
incident is based on
a self-evaluation
and as a result of what occurred in
columbine
what occurred in sacramento what
occurred in boston what occurred at the
pulse nightclub
police response has changed
by the fact that the fire department
standing with us is monumental okay
so we have found it's better instead of
securing a perimeter
and hoping the person doesn't continue
to
do acts of carnage associated with their
actions that uh even a small police
response will stop the suspect's actions
and so what are to answer your question
referenced mandalay bay
that training
we were listening and we were paying
attention
officers on their own without direction
of a supervisor knew what they had to do
they came together
formed a team made a response
and they didn't wait on
swat
okay they said we have to stop it's easy
to say we're waiting on swat they're the
experts in tactical intrusion
but our officers took it upon themselves
to act
no
patrol officers evaluated floor by floor
of the space between 29 and 32
where the suspect was
they formed the security uh they
evacuated rooms and they formed a
perimeter at the suspect's location
by unfortunate the
unfortunate acts of the suspect the
security guard was engaged during that
guard in process with officers or was
his finger alone he was acting
independently he got separated from our
team sure i just confirmed real fast
yesterday
but so the girlfriend is in the
i'm philippines saying she's located in
philippines
and you know what just so you know i'm
not giving you bad info no no okay
no
she was traveling
so subsequently
we have determined her location
okay
i'm sorry and i know it's
i you have to give me some some uh
deference
i'm currently done answering questions
okay um so i want to thank you carla do
we have any idea on
next conference time
okay hold on
that's not gospel
okay she hasn't talked to me yet i put
her on the spot
i put her on the spot but we'll
anticipate five o'clock thank you
thank you thank you
oh